plato in two of his texts and the
latches and the symposium explains how
socrates recalls an episode from the
famous battle of dilium in 424 bc
between the athenians and debbie oceans
the synopsis of his passage goes as
follows consider a soldier at the front
of the ocean line having the following
realization if our defense is successful
i still risk the chance of dying if our
defense is unsuccessful i will almost
certainly die based on this reasoning it
seems that the best alternative for the
soldier is to run away regardless of who
is going to win the battle now imagine
if all soldiers were to exhibit this
very reasoning at the same time if such
an event would occur they would all
probably realize that they would be
better off running away this seemingly
simple yet incredibly reasonable
hypothesis is one of the first
historical instances of game theory
flash forward 2
368 years in 1944 hungarian american
mathematician john von neumann published
a book titled theory of games and
economic behavior this foundational work
contains the method for finding mutually
consistent solutions for two-person
zero-sum games this great book
introduced game theory as a concept thus
extending its application to fields like
economics politics and sports and
leading to the expansion of the array of
scientists that showed interest in it
one of those scientists was the
legendary john nass who won the nobel
memorial prize in economic sciences in
1994 and popularized the idea of game
theory as we know it today
something very fundamental about game
theory is that it doesn't get its name
from the preconceived notion of a game
as we understand it
a game in game theory is an interaction
between multiple people in which each
person's payoff is affected by the
decisions of others
namely any interaction you're part of
under certain circumstances can be
analyzed with game theory in order to
produce the most beneficial outcome but
before we get into the mechanics let's
lay out the main principles
a game needs to include multiple players
the players need to interact with each
other there needs to be a reward we
assume that players act rationally we
assume that players act according to
their personal self-interest a skeptical
person would automatically assume that
these rules can be applied to real life
since most people operate in a strictly
emotional and irrational manner stay
with me for a second let's dive a bit
deeper and you will open your eyes to
probably the most important decision
making theory ever conceived
prisoner's dilemma is the most widely
mentioned game in game theory the basic
premise is how to establish a mutually
beneficial strategy between two members
of a gang that got arrested and face
potential imprisonment the rules are as
follows
the players of the game are prisoner a
and prisoner b
the players can't communicate with each
other if a and b each betray each other
each of them serves two years in prison
if a betrays b but b remains silent a
will be set free and b will serve three
years in prison and vice versa
if a and b both remain silent both of
them will only serve one year in prison
this matrix depicts the different
choices and its number signifies the
number of years to serve according to
each choice since both members can't
interact with each other the obvious
mutually beneficial choice here is to
betray choosing to remain silent
constitutes a high risk choice since the
other party could betray and the party
that remains silent will serve 3 years
in prison betraying sounds a bit cruel
but in this specific game it is optimal
stay with me and i will explain in a bit
how this strategy can actually change
game theorists usually coin the terms
dominant strategy and nas equilibrium to
distinguish the kind of strategies
followed by the players these two terms
are usually used together and form the
basis upon which game theory is founded
dominant strategy refers to strategies
that are better than other strategies
for one player no matter how the
opponent may play in the prisoner's
dilemma case the dominant strategy for
its player is to betray
the term nash equilibrium is used since
john nass explained the essentiality of
equilibrium and his landmark work
equilibrium points in any person games
in essence what he proposed is that even
in high-level competitive games like
google versus apple or usa versus russia
there exists an equilibrium where no
side would benefit by changing its
course at this equilibrium its side
knows its adversary very well and sticks
to its strategy for instance in the
prisoner's dilemma the nas equilibrium
is the bottom right square of the matrix
both prisoners to betray
what makes nasa's theory of equilibrium
so special is that it presupposes that
in each game there is at least one point
of equilibrium and all players will be
better off trying to find it and form
their strategy around it
this momentous revelation help people in
disciplines like politics war economics
business and social theory understand
the world better and form better
strategies the inception of nas
equilibrium was portrayed falsely in the
wonderful movie a beautiful mind
deep breaths
yes you might want to stop shuffling
your papers for five seconds
i will not buy you gentlemen beer oh
we're not here for beer my friend
oh [ __ ]
does anyone else feel she should be
moving in slow motion
will she want a large wedding you think
should we say swords gentlemen pistols
at dawn have you remembered nothing
recall the lessons of adam smith the
father of modern economics in uh in
competition individual ambition serves
the common good exactly every man for
himself gentlemen and those who strike
out are stuck with their friends
i'm not gonna strike out you can lead a
blonde to water but you can't make a
drink i don't think you said that all
right nobody move
she's looking over again she's looking
at nash oh god
all right he may have the upper hand now
but wait until he opens his mouth
[Music]
adam smith needs revision what are you
talking about
if we all go for the blonde
[Music]
we block each other not a single one of
us
is going to get her
so then we go for her friends
[Music]
but they will all give us the cold
shoulder because nobody likes to be
second choice
but what if no one goes for the blood
we don't get in each other's way
and we don't insult the other girls
that's the only way we win
that's the only way we all get laid
while this scene wants to point out the
importance of cooperation it's not an
example of nash equilibrium a nasa
equilibrium is only reached when all
players adopt a strategy where no single
player by changing his or her strategy
can obtain a better outcome in the
example shown in the movie that's not
the case assuming that everyone prefers
the blonde
any one of the guys could independently
change strategy by going for her
therefore if no one else goes after her
she could accept him and he could be the
only one ending up with her hence the
proposed strategy is not a nash
equilibrium and nash equilibrium is
really only obtained when all men follow
the strategy of going after the blonde
according to wikipedia researchers found
out that if two players play prisoners
dilemma more than once in succession and
they remember previous actions of their
opponent and changed their strategy
accordingly greedy strategies tended to
do very poorly in the long run while
more altruistic strategies did better
the researchers used this to show a
possible mechanism for the evolution of
altruistic behavior from mechanisms that
are initially purely selfish by natural
selection the essence of game theory is
that it looks at strategic decision
making and offers insight into the
dynamics of human rivalry apparently
even if people or companies rationally
follow their own self-interest the best
outcome is hard to reach when they count
or don't cooperate therefore the best
is for one to continually scan the
market for potential alliances and keep
playing games so that one can understand
them well that's what i love about game
theory it approaches the game of life
from its most axiomatic principle that
of evolution evolution equals adaptation
and therefore life is an omnipresent
game of adaptation humans always compete
at first but given the right
circumstances humans will choose
cooperation because it is the main
strategy that helped us survive and
thrive after years of adversity and
struggle to compete against different
forces of nature i always believed that
change and equilibrium start at the
micro level
and that is something we fail to grasp
because we are usually consumed by
events at the macro what each of us
could do is to use game theory in our
most challenging decisions and in our
closest relationships regardless of the
circumstance try to think like a game
theorist ponder questions like are the
actors in the situation rational are we
able to reach a nas equilibrium do they
act according to their self-interest do
they understand the rules of the game is
their dominant strategy really that
dominant if you see that most game
theory parameters aren't met you know
that you have to change your approach
you either need to also act irrationally
which is something i wouldn't suggest or
you need to step away and find better
players or games the choice is always
yours
life often times feels like a game and
we make the game better by learning how
to play
[Music]